how are you Brian I'm good rich thank
you very much what's going on Leonard
right now where where is that man what's
going on it's essentially what I love
more somewhere in LA I believe
okay so somewhere in Los Angeles best
weed we know are all as he met with all
three teams that are in this mix I don't
think I can't say for sure
I feel relatively confident and you know
relatively confident probably shouldn't
say it on the radio I don't know but
oh it's sports just just spitballing
over these met with the Clippers and
Lakers but you know this is unlike you
know in 2019 there's a pretty standard
free flow of information that comes out
on free agency like if you went back and
looked at the way Friedan Sea was
reported on as recently as like two
thousand thirteen or fourteen we didn't
have stuff like this sometimes a player
would sign and we wouldn't know the
contract numbers for two three days
there was like several different levels
now you know part of it is there's just
great reporting on it Adrian woods in
our schemes just you know he's one of
the best reporters in sports reporters
in the history of the the genre but you
know part of it it's become kind of
standard for things become public well
this is a throwback operation and I know
it's extremely frustrating for fans but
remember we waited nine days for LeBron
James back in 2010 you know we we waited
in when Kevin Durant once a Golden State
we waited till July force so this is you
know this is not what we've gotten used
to over the last few years but it's not
that unusual in sort of more old-school
terms and if you look at the way Kawhi
does business he's kind of an old-school
guy so this is just the way it is I know
it's people are on the edge of their
seat but that kind of makes them more
and more fun I think no III agree with
that I'm I'm fine waiting you know and
and certainly as somebody who does this
gig for a living Brian I wouldn't mind
if he waits till next week I mean I got
five shows next week it would be great
to have him announced let's see I
actually have that list right here in
front of me I believe the first camp to
open air
ona in Baltimore on the 17th so we've
got some time to kill that's when my
summer starts is when was when the
football starts flying for years when my
summer starts I'm counting down baby
when the ball gets more oblong is when
you get head to forget my name of the
SPS they won't even know I well I mean
cool I could change all that but you
know you know so let me let me ask you
this is it possible there's a fourth
team in that we don't know about no I
don't think so
I think it's studying it's a three-team
race I think it's a complex decision for
him because I think all three are pretty
different and I think that that's one of
the reasons why you might be taking some
time here is I think if he's going to
make this choice it's it's really going
to be an important moment in his career
and you know he may put these team
there's a lot to go over especially if
you know when you're meeting with the
Lakers especially this is what I've
tried to explain to people there seems
to be this this feeling that the Lakers
have some sort of advantage because
they've been very active lately they've
added and Anthony Davis and they you
know wiped out the rest of their roster
to open the cap space what really has
happened is they've just changed
everything
recently you know they recently changed
their training staff they briefly
changed their head coach they recently
changed their front office structure so
Kawhi Leonard as he's been thinking
about this over the last six months he
knows everything is going on Toronto he
was there he knows what the Clippers had
he's aware the Clippers were recruiting
him for months on end he he knows that
everything about Doc Rivers he knows
their roster he knows their their
structure of management Jerry West the
Lakers are all new so one of the reasons
why he's going to do information
gathering on the Lakers is because he
didn't have a lot of information and I
think one of the things that's happened
is as he has gathered information
there's been this sort of rush to
judgment that that means he's going to
to go play for them and like oh he wants
to talk to Magic Johnson oh he must be
going to play for them no he wants to
Magic Johnson's he wants to know what
the hell going on with that organization
now he may end up doing that he may end
up being you know is satisfied with what
he hears and be excited about it but
that's one thing that I've noticed
last week is people are confusing you
know activity with accomplishment and I
think that's something you should think
about is you figure out what quiet try
to feel what quiet well there's also a
lot of Brian when works from ESPN here
on the Richard show there's still
there's also a lot of whispers coming
out of the Lakers organization that they
the folks that he's talked to LeBron and
magic are their aces in a hole because
they're LeBron and magic and also that
LeBron and magic have indicated to all
those who are interested in that place
that they that they've gotten the
positive vibes from Kawhi why why are we
if you're not supposed to talk about
Fight Club with Kawhi Leonard why are we
hearing about the Fight Club
conversations with the Lakers in Kawhi
Leonard so much we haven't heard about
how I don't know if that's aI don't know
if that's true rich I mean I if they put
this why I keep hearing all of these
things about Kawhi and I go to
investigate them and I can't prove any
of them are true just can't you know
again that's not normally where we are
in today's day and age we hear a rumor
usually between myself that low Ramona
Shelburne and Adrienne we normally can
run it down pretty quick you know with
you know with the between between us at
ESPN in our connections and even Steven
a we usually lose that definitely people
we can't get to we're not getting
information here I I'm just trying to be
honest so I don't feel confident in
anything that has come out there yet
about about him at all doesn't mean it's
not true we just can't prove it so then
let's get to the to the analysis portion
of this then which team if they are left
empty in the kauai sweepstakes which
plan B is the worst case with which team
would have the biggest problem with a
plan B in this Toronto I mean other than
the fact that they're holding the trophy
I mean it's uh you know it's it's gonna
be disappointing it I sort of compare it
to you know the Cavs in 2016
the Warriors land Kevin Durant three
weeks after they won the title and it
was a real bummer for them and kind of
signaled their endows chance to be a
champion again but they were still
holding it you know so in the Raptors
have no functional way to replace him
they would fall out of
contention they might even start a
rebuild because half their team is on
the last year of its contracting they
had some good young players I'm not
saying they were started immediately but
I think that they would consider
starting it there the there would be the
biggest losers other than fact they have
the trophy so no one feels bad for them
and they shouldn't feel bad for
themselves
sure but you know when you look at it
from a I spent about an hour yesterday
with Patrick Beverley who just signed a
3-year 40 million dollar deal to stay
with the Clippers and he was talking to
me about his meeting with the Clippers
when they made their free agent
presentation to him and he got offered
more money to go elsewhere he got
offered 50 million to go play for the
Kings 10 million dollars to a guy who
hasn't made 100 million in his career
it's not nothing and he was talking
about how exciting excited he is about
the Clippers plans and their options and
the renovations that they're doing at
their facility and the new arena that
Steve Ballmer wants to build now granted
he's on the Clippers team I'm not
expecting him to be critical sir but I
mean the Clippers have a very strong
pitch now the Lakers pitch is we are the
Lakers and if you join us we could have
one of the strongest try embrace in
history of the game I'm not I'm not
debating that I mean it is incredibly
compelling and Kauai grew up in Southern
California when the Lakers were winning
championships he probably went to
Staples Center and was in awe of the
place as I was the first time I walked
in there in the early 2000s and watch -
at Kobe game I still have I still get
goose bumps thinking about it I mean I
keep if he chooses the Lakers I would
understand you I wouldn't take any
explanation for me whatsoever I get it
but the Clippers has his very very very
compelling situation and I know that
it's very hard to believe that unless
you've been really following the NBA
over the last few years but just about
everything the Clippers done for the
last two years has been pitch perfect
they've made great smart intelligent
move after the other they just made a
terrific trade this week and I'll bet
the average NBA fan would have no idea
what it is
they
traded mote they traded for most
heartless who's a quality defensive
player and got a first-round draft pick
just for taking on him on that's not
exciting there's a really smart move
they've got their entire roster is made
up of guys on great contracts they have
three extra first-round draft picks they
have two players who were who are all
refused this year that were on their
team they are they have the richest
owner in in in American sports they have
a coach who everybody wants to play for
they have Jerry West in there there's a
lot a play in Los Angeles there's a lot
going for them in a vacuum get Kawhi was
picking the best organization I think
the Clippers would have a really
compelling case Brian I am so lockstep
with you on that because I would kind of
need however an explanation not that I
would
you know receive it or or demand it but
I'd I'd like to know why Kawhi would
after what he just did in Toronto and
understanding what what came his way if
he does care at all about the accolades
of going was spot and making it his own
and putting his stamp on a spot that
needed a stamp in the most desperate way
that he would then go ahead and join a
spot with two remarkable players and
talents and personality and obviously
LeBron why he would go ahead in and do
that and be part of a triumvirate as
opposed to his own thing it would be the
same thing in for the Clippers in
Toronto with out the the Canada part
it's the same thing they're desperate
for him they're desperate for their own
identity they're desperate for the
greatest player in the history of their
franchise and they would roll it out I
mean and and that's on top of everything
you just said I'm so locked up with you
as for the Clippers period because
because America loves the Kennedys and
the kid who has the perfect SAT score
the extracurriculars and the great essay
sometimes it doesn't get into Harvard
when the legacy kid does
because that's lured in the Lakers are
the legacy and that's America and you
know that the Clippers have done
everything you possibly can right but
they're still the Clippers and they
always will be now we we just saw the
net that that 50-year script with the
Nets joining the world in the middle of
the 70s in the New York area that's that
just finally got that script just got
flipped after a half century Brian
period another period I don't want to go
I don't want to make this like - like
shank PC ok like something you would
read in The New Yorker but hawai holds
the super team air in his hand right now
if Kauai goes to the Clippers a super to
Mary is dead we would we would have no
super teams even the net I know their
own is excited about him they're not the
same team that the Warriors were or that
the that the he that the Heat were
before them or that even the Celtics
were or even that the Cavs were with had
three all-stars at one time they would
not be that team the Lakers and the
Thunder you know are you look look the
Thunder they have to all NBA players the
Lakers would have to all NBA players you
know a budget you know that the the
Spurs have two all-stars
DeMar DeRozan and Marcus Aldridge you
would do a deal a way bigger feeling of
parity in the league now the Lakers are
still gonna be compelling team the Nets
would still be compelling but the super
team era was essentially had been killed
meanwhile Dwight picks the Lakers we may
have the greatest super team we've ever
seen so he's holding I mean I'm not
saying he gives a crap about that
responsibility but as you're looking at
the lay of the land he's holding it
we've just seen Durant in Kauai flip the
Knicks testing on a 10th of Kauai one of
the most impactful free agents in the
history of the game I mean right up
there with LeBron and Durant this is
like his hobby you know one see to those
two he picks the Clippers over the
Lakers when the Lakers have a great team
in an open roster spot sitting right
there with the league wide open
I mean a team to Kauai picks is going to
be the favorite to win the title I'm not
saying they will but they're going to be
the favorite
that's an incredible moment he's making
extraordinary wide-ranging decisions on
a wide-ranging implications not only on
this season but on this era there's no
doubt about it
Brian when we're here on the Rich Eisen
show last one for you here so the Lakers
what is their what would their plan B be
I mean you know Jared Dudley there was a
nice signing a lot of folks here we're
we're talking about that yesterday about
it that that's a neat piece to add to
the Lakers what would their plan B be if
Kauai does not come here with all that
money well the one thing I need Davis I
would raise my hand and say hey did I
sign that paperwork to give up that four
million dollar trade kicker is I'm not
striking about four million dollars to
pay an extra four million bucks $200 you
know you're Michael Green but I think it
would that would you would get a buyout
in Memphis he'd be a strong candidate to
join them I think Marcus I think Marcus
Morris who is probably the most
interested unsigned player in my opinion
I think he goes whoever doesn't get
Kawhi I think if he is he goes to the
Clippers if they don't get him he goes
the Lakers but they don't get them
that's a player I think rajon rondo will
be back with the Lakers I think the only
thing that's the question is what his
salary will be it'll be less if Kauai
goes there will be more if Kauai doesn't
go there and there's a handful of other
you know guys who are not bad additions
you know I can sit here and go on and on
I don't know if you're sure let's just
repair about me talking about the eighth
or ninth guy to make it sign of garlic
Ian Clark would be a nice addition the
Lakers would be able to feel the very
competitive team but they get Kawhi
again it's potentially historically
great team they could could run off a
couple in a row so you know they there's
probably been at least in my mind 15
plus guys that I thought that the Lakers
would have liked to have signed that
have gone off the board while they've
been waiting you know even yesterday
Jeff Green Jeff Greene's a guy who has
proven he can be effective alongside
LeBron he played the best game of his
career in Game seven
in Boston two years ago helped LeBron
into the finals he signs with Utah that
would have been a really nice addition
for the Lakers but it's worth wait it's
they have to wait they have
let these things go all these other
players they can are somewhat
replaceable Kauai is not Brian you the
man thanks once again love it love our
chats and and before the the ball gets
oblong I want I'll get you on one more
time and then send you off to your
vacation before I bother you one more
time all right thanks enjoy your holiday
that's you too that's Brian when Horst
at one-horse tspn for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app